رئيسة مجلس النواب نانسي بيلوسي في
طريقها إلى المحيط الهادئ حيث
ستزور حلفاء الولايات المتحدة مثل اليابان وكوريا الجنوبية
وماليزيا وسنغافورة مع زملائها
من أعضاء الكونغرس الذين تسافر معهم
ولكن يبقى السؤال الرئيسي
حول هذه الرحلة هل تسافر في
تايوان  زيارة الجزيرة في الوقت الحالي ،
لا يزال هذا احتمالًا مؤقتًا ولكن
لا توجد إجابة حازمة في مؤتمرها الصحفي الأسبوعي
يوم الجمعة ، فهي ببساطة لن
تقدم إجابة قائلة إنها مسألة
أمنية ، فقد طور البنتاغون الذي تعلمناه
طبقات من الحماية وخطة
مطبقة  إذا ذهبت إلى الجزيرة
للتأكد من أنها آمنة هناك باستخدام
ربما سفن طائرات ربما
تستخدم الأقمار الصناعية لمراقبة مكانها
والمنطقة المحيطة بها حتى يكون هناك
مزيد من الوضوح حول ما إذا كانت
ستزور تايوان الآن ، فهذا معيار
لأي  كبار الشخصيات يزور تايوان ولكن بالطبع
هذا أكبر بكثير من ذلك
لأنه المتحدث باسم المنزل
وقد عمل مسؤولو الأمن القومي
خلف الكواليس.  لمحاولة إقناع
بيلوسي بالمخاوف المحيطة بهذه الرحلة ، لكنها
تصر على أن هذا سيكون قرارها هنا
وقد دعمها أعضاء آخرون في الكونجرس
الآن وقد استخدمت الصين
خطابًا متقلبًا على نحو متزايد حول
إمكانية هذه الرحلة عندما
جاءت قضية تايوان.  بين الرئيس جو
بايدن والرئيس شي جينبينغ قالت ،
وفقًا لوسائل الإعلام الحكومية الصينية ،
إذا لعبت بالنار ستحترق
ورأينا هذا من الصين تضغط
ضد احتمال القيام بهذه الرحلة ،
لكن أعضاء الكونجرس وآخرين
أخبروا بيلوسي بذلك.  يجب أن يكون قرارها
وليس قرارًا اتخذه الصينيون بشأن
الصين ، فليس مجرد خطاب
نراه يوم السبت أنهم قالوا
إنهم سيخوضون تمرينًا بالذخيرة الحية
في مقاطعة فوجيان القريبة جدًا من
تايوان هذا قبل ما قد يحدث.  be a
pelosi visit to taiwan وتقول تايوان
إنهم رصدوا طائرة بدون طيار مجهولة الهوية على
جزيرة تسيطر عليها تايوان تحلق
في المنطقة التي قالوا إنها قد تستخدم
لجمع المعلومات  CE على الرغم
من أنهم لم
يذكروا الصين في البيان ، لذا فهي
لحظة حرجة للغاية هنا ، ومن الجدير بالذكر
أنه لا يوجد مسؤول دفاع تحدثنا
معه هنا في البنتاغون يتوقع
أن يكون هناك نوع من النشاط الحركي لا
إطلاق نار بين الصينيين  الطائرات أو
السفن الصينية والمعدات العسكرية الأمريكية
، السؤال هو ما الذي يمكن أن يفعلوه
على الطريق سواء كان ذلك
تفاعلات
واعتراضات أكثر عدوانية للطائرات والسفن
ليس فقط الولايات المتحدة ولكن أيضًا الحلفاء ،
فهذه هي الاحتمالات
لكيفية رد فعل الصين على بيلوسي  زيارة إلى تايوان
وارين ليبرمان CNN في البنتاغون